[Music]  Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd  are married it's a great feeling  [Music]  the Dancing with the Stars pros tied the  knot on Saturday at the Oheka Castle in  Long Island New York which you might  recognize from Taylor Swift's blank  space music video and our action names  the couple's five month-old son shy  served as Prince of Honor while they're  dancing co-stars Sharna Burgess and Tony  Dovolani were in the bridal party the  lovebirds got engaged in December 2015  and a week later PETA gushed to et about  why max is the man for her I couldn't  see myself with anybody else  so he's like literally the love of my  life  [Music]  you  [Music]